Hello Freak bitches.
I also don't know if life can actually
evolve and progress just through pure
logic or pure rationality.
I think chance is very important in life
and I also think being creative and
creative must to some extent involved.
That ridiculousness at least must
involve the question of asking why now
it might get more logical and rational
as we go forward,
but I'm not sure we're ever going to
completely be the perfect mathematical
model that we would want to be A.
I'm not even sure that if we had perfect
intelligence,
if let's just say hypothetically we
became that perfect intelligence.
We might purposely sabotage ourselves
just so that we always have that element
of irrationality in our lives to keep us
on the go,
to keep us moving forward,
to keep us evolving.
So I'm.
So that's the first part of that.
I think the second part of what you're
speaking about,
the the interesting thing that I always
tell people,
because I get asked this question a lot,
is that right now our current perception
of the universe is pretty limited.
For example,
our ISI can only see about one percent
of the light spectrum.
Our ears can hear far less than one
percent of the of the sound waves and
what's possible in the universe,
so our actual ability to determine what
is in the universe is completely
limited,
in fact,
so limited that were were just basically
getting tiny bits of it.
As we get,
as we progress forward,
I think we're going to have apps,
a more applications towards getting a
better perception and our senses of what
the universe really entails.
We'll all have night vision will have be
able to see different types of gases in
the air and we'll we'll have different
types of feelings that are based in with
with this,
these kind of a hypersensitive and that
in itself will give us so many new
experiences and I try to tell this to
people a lot that we're actually going
to become much more complex.
We think this is our world around us,
but actually if you and I had bionic
eyes,
we'd see that there are maybe a billion
different organisms in this room that
are also interacting with us.
And that's something that,
I'm not saying it's gonna maybe take us
down a,
either a smart or a bad path,
but it's something that could be
different,
that could take us to other ideas and
other ways of experiencing the world
that makes it so it's not either boring
or makes it so it's not.
So,
you know,
so kinda crazy though.
I,
you know,
I don't think that humans are ever gonna
end transhumans at least to start with
are going to give up some of the
ridiculous aspects of their life because
I'm.
One of the things that motivates us is
fun and one of the things in,
in human experience that is fun is being
ridiculous.
So I think you need that creativity.
You need that creative element in the
species.
I think that most I've ever done was I
think $10,000 to some corporate event.
It wasn't.
People showed up to see me.
I was a Sammy Hagar was on and Steve
Miller,
I was on.
Wow.
You worked a Sammy Hagar and Steve.
But what does Steve Miller looked like?
Did you even recognize them?
A.
No,
because the album was the white horse
lake,
so my whole teenage years of listened
to.
I've never saw what he looked like.
He looked like a dad with a blazer and
jeans and just went out there.
That's the thing about Steve Miller.
He is the least recognizable major.
He walk around Rockstar.
He could walk around anywhere and it
seemed like he never tried to become
famous or you're going to out him on the
podcast that Steve Miller.
That's what it looks like now.
Dude.
He had some fucking jams.
Jungalow love that was high school.
That whole album reminds me of high
school.
Take the money alone.
This is a story about Billy Joe.
We thought we thought we were cool too
because we're listening to classic rock.
That was technically they were into this
stuff,
not this new edition.
You know?
It's really fucking weird,
man.
I went to high school in 1981 and in
1981 I started hanging out with these
kids.
I just moved into town into a Newton
upper falls and I started hanging out
with my friend Jimmy and Jimmy and all
of his friends were all,
uh,
from the other side of town there.
They're all like the north part of
Newton and they were all like,
everyone had doors,
tee shirts and they were all smoking
weed and it was like they introduced me
to all this music that I didn't even
know existed.
But when I think about it now,
the shit was only 10 years old.
Yeah.
Like the allman brothers,
they were,
they were playing like some allman
brothers are some doors.
That shit is from like 1969,
1970.
So at the time we're talking wwe,
I went to high school in [inaudible] 81.
That was my freshman year.
So this is,
what is it,
12,
13 years old as fuck.
Nothing.
That's like some music from 2001 that's
contemporary,
you know,
like a song from 2002.
You could still hear like on a regular
basis that would be on a radio station
that was eighties,
nineties and hits sex and can.
Yeah,
you can hear that.
You could easily hear that someone could
play that non.
Ironically on a regular radio station,
they wouldn't be saying,
oh,
you remember this shit.
That would be a song that would play,
but that sex and candy song came out and
like,
like 99 or some shit.
Yeah.
So think about that.
Like that.
We wouldn't say,
yeah man,
that was the classic.
Something fucking happened to time,
right?
Time is not what it used to be 10 years
ago doesn't mean shit anymore,
but 10 years ago back then meant a lot
when I was in high school and then in
1981 and 1970 car was a mother fucker.
If you had a 1970 Chevelle or a 1970
barracuda,
you add a fucking sweet car.
Oh,
you got a classic muscle car.
It's only 10 years old.
What the fuck happened?
And he does that when it happened.
The acceleration,
just information.
We're pumped.
We're going to the library every single
second.
We look at her phone,
you know,
that's what's happening,
right?
That is what's happening.
That's deep.
It's cleaned my bedroom the other day
and I have a pretty big bed,
but underneath the bed it's
like in the middle you'll never get
anything on,
you know,
like if something falls under the bed.
So I was trying to get everything and I
pulled out a single cheeseburger from
Mcdonald's that I guess I was eating and
I like threw,
threw it on the ground or something and
it just went in there and get it to you.
I know you live like I haven't had
mcdonalds in my bed for at least six
months and so that.
But when I opened it,
it looked brand new.
It looked just exactly the same.
You would buy it at perfect apartments,
like the raft of a survivor's stranded
at sea.
It's just scattered disarray with
bobbers and nets and one shoe
pirate in the corner for some reason.
Yeah.
That big area in the middle where you
can reach under your bed area is a
problem.
It's disgusting because if you ever do
move your bed,
your bed,
you're like looking at it going,
that's so gross.
How much would I have to pay you to lick
that center area where you can't reach?
Just do the whole line on the line from
the head to the.
Keep your tongue down on the ground from
the foot of the bed to the head of the
bed.
Like an Imac
could only take an imac to get you to do
that.
Hello?
Yeah.
Wow.
What about Ipad mini?
I licked.
I licked the bowl.
I licked the stripper pole at a crazy
girl is a couple of months ago on stage
because we were doing comedy there and I
just said some hot girl just got off and
I was like,
damn,
that girl is hot.
And I just like licked it as a joke.
Everyone was like,
oh,
but then I thought about it and then I
had like a canker on my time for like
three days.
Welcome to the wonderful world of new
AIDS canker on your dog.
I was freaked out for a couple of days,
but it was so hilarious.
That is so hilarious.
David Arquette owns that place now and I
told him like he would.
He did kill Tony and I told him about
that.
You just give me a high five.
He's like,
that's great.
That's hilarious.
He owns a strip club.
What a good move for a fucking celebrity
that's just getting divorced.
What an excellent move and that places
a.
They do comedy occasionally there.
Yeah,
they do.
Shows are like music sometimes and that
it's totally not set up for comedy
though because they have like a strobe
light facing the comic.
So you're onstage and you're just having
elliptic caesars and you can't see
anything.
Pick seizures,
whatever.
Elliptical seizures.
Epileptic you fuck
wrong
ellipses.